clear them
is everybody here
pretty much
good morning everybody
uh
welcome to our
first executive session
of the year
we have um
we have four bills
to um
discuss this morning
so if we could um
let's start with hb
1300 and
um
it's been recommended for
interim study
representative lin would you like to
speak to this please
sure um the recommendation for interim
study of results from the fact that as
uh the original request
in this bill was for a 500 000
appropriation
for the ash landfill
the money was
intended to
make up for
it if
make up for a shortfall in what
the department of environmental services
says is the amount that should be kept
as a for lack of a better term as a sort
of bond
in the event that
um
the the current operators of the
landfill which is a non-profit
organization were to
kind of go out of business so to speak
and the the state were required to take
over the landfill um and and you know to
if there was some problem what is the
amount of money that would be needed to
to correct the problem
the
the difficulty here is that
the need for this arose from the fact
that at the time the the
non-profit was first established i think
it was in the early 90s
to
take care of
the landfill the des regulations at that
time
said that there had to be sufficient
money in in a bond-like
structure to take care of the landfill
for a 30-year period
um and so the the operators of landfill
believe that as time went on and that
they got closer to the end of that
30-year period they were entitled to
spend some money out of the out of out
of the uh
the bond fund if you will for the
ongoing operating expenses of the of the
landfill
later after this uh
after the the uh the non-profit
organization uh was established and had
done this des changed its regulations
they say
it was merely a classification i mean a
clarification but
i think to a lot of us on division two
it seemed like it was really a change in
the regulations that says
that now says the 30-year period is a is
an ongoing
rolling 30-year period it's sort of an
effect is perpetual and and in light of
that the the uh landfill was was below
what it should have had uh
in discussions as we as we proceeded
through this it appears very likely that
that
um the state and the and the operators
of landfill are going to be able to come
to an agreement to resolve this
uh this matter and probably i don't know
this for sure but probably it's going to
involve something along the lines of
that the state is going to recognize
that they kind of change the regulations
and they're going to say look we're just
we're not going to bring an enforcement
action against you
um
i don't know that for sure but the state
and the and the operators of landfill
apparently feel very confident that they
will be able to come to a resolution
there was no sense on division two among
anyone that we should uh appropriate the
five hundred thousand dollars and we
thought that the interim study was the
best way to deal with it okay
thank you
are there any questions
yeah i'll second that motion uh okay
thank you
okay uh joe would you i'm sorry
representative petry would you please
call the roll
thank you madam chair
uh representative weiler yes
president
yes
representative petry volchies
representative emmerich yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards
yes
representative bean is not here
representative lynn
yes
representative mooney
representative turcotte yes
representative walner
yes
representative norgren
no that's uh
representative long i'm sorry
um
original pukko
yes
represent the leashman
okay
representative hatch yes
representative rogers
representative walsh
president excuse me
you very much
president of heath yes
rosanna murray
man of chair of the vote is 18 to
nothing
don't forget me
19.
why should i forget you i don't know 19
i'm sorry
representative i'm burger just for the
record uh thank you i'm sorry i did not
mention to start off that uh
representative long is sitting in for
representative nordgren
and representative shertliff is sitting
in for uh representative walls welcome
to
to finance
i know represent long has been sitting
with us for
several sessions and
we thank him for that
okay which calendar
oh yes is there anyone that objects to
consent
okay seeing none we'll press on
hb 1054
requiring an audit of the state police
where uh representative mooney
thank you madam chair i'd like to make a
motion of itl on house bill 1054 and i'd
like to speak to my motion
please
thank you
thank you madam chair a few points on
this bill
you may recall uh the sponsor
spoke very briefly and he asked us to
itl the bill
upon further research it appears as i
know most of you are familiar but the
legislative performance audit and
oversight committee typically requests
audits they did not do so in this case
for state police
and then thirdly it appears that the
office of the legislative budget
assistant completed a financial audit of
the state police for the period ending
on march 31
2019 so to spend state resources on an
audit that was performed so recently is
unnecessary so for that reason i would
encourage all of you to vote on
t l thank you madam chair okay thank you
are there any questions that anyone has
just just hatched just to point i i
think wasn't the bill asking for a
performance audit not a financial audit
and they're they're bifurcated they're
two entirely different things that's
just a
point represent mooney
oh thank you representative for the
question on a good point and on line
four of the bill it reads the audit
shall include an assessment of the
proficiency
structure
financial dealings
and services provided by the
organization so
yes and all that's included thank you
okay there any further questions
seeing none will the clerk call the role
thank you manager uh this is house bill
1054.
the motion is to itl
representative weiler
hi
president the burris
yes
arizona petrie votes yes
representative emmerich yes
representative erf yes
representative griffin
representative edwards yes
uh representative beans over here
representative lynn
yes
representative mooney
uh representative turcotte yes
representative wallner
okay
okay norgrin is uh shirtless long
representative long yes
arizona pukko
yes
oh there's a leashman's over here
representative hatch yes
representative uh
rogers
representative shirtless
president of heath yes
representative murray
representative von burger yes
madam chair the vote is 19 to nothing
for ito
does anyone have a problem if we put
this on the consent calendar
so be it
okay we now move to um hb 103.
madam chair i'd like to make a motion
that we pass hb 103
uh otp a
with uh amendment
0904 hotel
as the amended version
do i have a second
second
would you like to speak to your motion
uh yes ma'am um
okay so the legislature has a history
with um
wanting uh or attempting to add an adult
dental benefit to medicaid
and
sort of the classic
arguments have been
that this good dental care is good
health care and
we should go ahead and make sure that
our citizens have good health care
the other view has been
that
we we should not be in a position to
continually expand medicaid
due to the cost of the taxpayers and
some questions about the uh
efficiency of the of the program so
those are the two classic cases what
what we've tried to do with 103 in
division three
is
and with me personally is i've i've
worked with
hhs's working group
for many many months
and we have come to an accommodation
between these two
yes or no positions
where
we're trying to say yes in a way in
which it recognizes some some core
principles
we
are
acknowledging
that
individuals are the ones who are
primarily responsible for their own oral
health they without the individual
involvement uh you it does it doesn't
matter what somebody tries to do for you
you're just not gonna have good uh
dental care
so we've established in it to
to reflect the individual responsibility
a co-pay so that only those making at
least 100 percent of the federal poverty
level
would contribute 10 towards their pay
this is a fairness issue because pretty
much everyone who has dental insurance
in the state has to pay something for it
and so this is this is our saying we're
not giving this category of people a
free benefit they have to buy in just
like everyone else has to buy in the
other thing is on the dentures
we
limited it to those who seem to be in a
situation to be responsible for the care
of the dentures so those in
long-term nursing facilities and then
choices for independence they would be
eligible
and
and also the developmentally disabled
community would would be
eligible
so you know that le that that carve out
does leave out a
pretty significant number of people
but we've gotten i've gotten assurances
from
one of the mcos that they
will seriously look at providing the
denture care to those who are not
eligible on a charitable basis because
that's part of their their mission and
they've been doing that for adults
for years now we put a cap on it for
fifteen hundred dollars and we found a
source of the initial funding from the
centene settlement fund that that's was
reflected in the senate version of this
and so we borrowed what they did
um and so
we're going to uh we're proposing to
take 18.4 million of the centene
settlement fund
the
senate version also wanted to fund 2.4
million of that
settlement fund for something called a
risk corridor we had no hearings on the
risk corridor so we just carved it out
in the amendment
so um i would uh ask that you uh vote
for this um amended version um
uh i i know uh
several people will not
because of the concern about expansion
of the medicaid program i respect that
position
um
but nevertheless i think this is a a
good way to proceed that accommodates uh
historic
interests on both sides of the bill so
thank you madam chair
thank you are there any questions for
representative edwards
seeing none will the clerk please call
the role
thank you madam chair
uh original wilder yes
president the burj yes
rich representative petrie volcano
representative emerick yes
representative erf yes
representative griffin
representative edwards yes
lin
no
representative mooney
representative turcotte
no
representative walner
yes
representative long yes
representative bucco
yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers
representative shirtless
representative heath yes
representative murray
representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote is 14-5
in favor of octopass as amended
thank you very much um
oh so madam chair i just add that i've
i've sent you a committee report on this
that should be able to be used
okay
yeah uh will there be a minority report
yes there will be okay and you will
prepare that uh
we'll talk amongst ourselves and figure
it out get that back to you on who
exactly will do that okay
if nobody else volunteers i will do that
all right because we'll need it uh
tomorrow morning at the latest
okay
okay um oh should i put this on the
consent calendar
this yeah yeah i agree this will go on
the regular calendar
unfortunately there's some kind of rule
out there that says anytime you're
spending money that
it needs to go on the regular calendar
so
what can i say
okay
the next one is hb 1677
as amended
as otpa with
five 0956 h
so madam chair i'd like to make a motion
that we ex
uh uh accept this amendment zero nine
five six h and pass the bill out of
committee otpa
do i have it second griffin thank you
who's that griffin
no edwards and griffin
thank you
um
if you don't mind i would like to speak
to this just briefly
uh
i have no idea how many hours
we have spent working through
this bill
and it's not only been in uh
work sessions but also outside of work
sessions
the goal of
1677 as amended
is to provide an alternative way
to settle
cases
that we anticipate will be brought
against the youth development center and
when we say youth development center
it's the whole gamut i don't care what
you call it
uh whether it's um
you know sununu or the ydc or i don't
know there were several others in there
but this spans the entire entire
gamut of
youth incarceration
the um
the process that we have uh established
with this
amendment
is that anyone a claimant
can
bring a
claim
to the ag's designee
who will determine
[Music]
what sort of
settlement
there will be
we have capped
sexual abuse at 1.5 million
and we have capped fiscal abuse at 150
000.
uh if the claimant accepts the
ag designee's position
we're very happy about that
if the claimant does not accept
the ag designee's position
they have an opportunity to
withdraw
and go to court
or they have the opportunity
to go to what we are calling
an administrator
that will be working for the supreme
court
and
then
that person
will
decide what the final award will be
so
then
prior to all of this starting
the ag
and the
claimants council as we know
them to be now
will set up uh guidelines
for
the um
the the award
and um
mary jane insisted i'm sorry
representative walner insisted that that
come to the fiscal committee
for
for approval
so
is that is that correct
anyhow so it will be coming back to the
fiscal committee for approval
and uh we felt that um because this is
dealing with money and awards
and um
how
how this whole system is going to work
that we felt that um this was an
appropriate place
because it involves both the house and
the senate
um
finally
uh i'll just say that uh
if
oh we we did basically set aside 100
million dollars
for these these settlements
and uh
hopefully we can
you know it'll it'll be the 100 million
will cover it
if it doesn't
sometime in the future
the ag has the option of coming back
to
the
legislature
for additional funds
but we are hoping against hope
that the hundred million will cover
uh the cost of the uh
of these claimants that that are out
there so
that's where we stand and i would simply
ask that you please
vote yes
are there any
questions or comments uh yes represent
rogers
um first of all i want to commend the
the folks all of us worked on this and
and it's a much better bill with the
amendment than it was when it came in
and by and large it's a great bill
however there are two points that i
think um
we need to consider and the reason i
can't support it at this time
um one capping the settlements at the
amounts that representative umber talked
about i don't think is fair
we've had a number of cases that have
come out of the federal court that have
had much larger awards so the claimants
if we want them to come to this
instead of going to court civil court on
their own i think we need to be
realistic so i think we need to raise
that cap
um
from the 1.5 and 150 000 the second
point is the scope of the abuse
we've limited the scope of the abuse i
think we need to broaden it
remember we're talking about over or
close to 50 years of abuse that's
happened
while the state
had custody of these children
i know that they're not all children now
but still
we had a duty
to care for these people
and we failed in that duty
um
and i think by not including all abuse
that we're not being fair we're saying
one victim is better than the other
i would hope that we could include
things such as
emotional abuse and especially unlawful
confinement
we know that there are um
plaintiffs that were put into solitary
confinement for up to six months time
and we've got a lot of literature a lot
of studies that have shown that solitary
confinement is terribly
terribly harmful to a child
and it's almost like these were the
forgotten children we put them in here
we abused them we threw them into
solitary confinement we did other things
i think if we're going to own up which
we are and that's why this is such a
great bill happening now and i
especially commend the sponsors like
representative umberger for doing this
but
we need to include everyone we can't be
selective so for those two points
um
i know we made great progress and as i
said i think this is a good bill but it
could be better so that's why i can't
support it at this time
thank you
are there any other comments or
questions
uh representative wallner thank you um
chairman ember
i do agree with uh representative rogers
that there are a couple of um
outstanding issues that we did not
resolve as we
worked on this amendment
i am going to support the bill because i
feel like it is
the state's responsibility to set up
this settlement fund
and
the um i think that what we've got here
is something that will be very helpful
to the claimants and to the victims
and provide a process that will be
much friendlier
than if people have to end up going to
court
so for those reasons i'm going to
support the bill i am
still concerned about the two areas that
we didn't seem to get a resolution
for but
as we know in legislation things leave
the house and go over to the senate and
then they get to put their mark on it so
we'll see what happens over there so for
those reasons i am going to support the
bill okay thank you are there any other
uh comments
seeing none will the clerk call the role
thank you madam chair representative
weiler yes
representative burris yes
representative petrie volch yes
representative emrick yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin
representative edwards
yes
representative lynn
representative mooney
yes
representative turcotte yes
representative walner
yes
representative long
bernard pucco yes
representative hatch yes
representative rogers
shirtless
president of heath yes
president of murray
oh i'm sorry
aha snuck in representative leishman
yes
and representative umberger yes
uh the vote is 19 to one
and i thought this could go on the
consent calendar as well but
yeah regular calendar
okay and um
there will be a minority report
on hb 1677
representative rogers
okay
uh representative rogers your minority
report is due tomorrow
okay great
and what what would that be
itl
okay so does that mean you're going to
have a floor amendment
okay
all right
we have a one o'clock hearing
on a non-germane amendment
uh
so
uh other
is there anything else to be
brought before this group
boy that was the fastest executive
session on record for finance so
i guess
i guess we should keep it up i'm sorry i
probably should have scheduled the
non-germain bill a little bit earlier
but
i had no idea so
thank you all very much and i'll see you
at one o'clock
labor day yeah well not every year is
going to be labor day week
i didn't know they could do this but
they changed it
okay i will call the
finance committee to order and
the purpose of this public hearing
is to
discuss a non-germane amendment
and unfortunately my name is at the top
i thought maybe we could put
representative heath's name there or
somebody but
so
if you will excuse me i will go to the
other table
and
let you know what this amendment's all
about
okay
we'll call a meeting to order to open
the discussion on the amendment to hb
1627 fna we're having a separate hearing
because it is non-germane to the
underlying bill and we'll call on the
sponsor representative umberger and ask
her to be sure and fill out a pink sheet
oh shoot
yes there is one over there i apologize
i forgot all about i don't see any other
pink sheets okay
well mark is going to come up and talk
as well so
division 2 and the education committee
have been involved in an interim study
on
various issues with school funding
and as we have been uh
discussing that it came up
that it would be wonderful
if we had a way
uh to
combine
uh the information from medicaid
into
the free and reduced lunch program
and uh we worked with hhs
and
doe to see
how that could occur
well it appears that the department of
agriculture has a
pilot program going on
that allows the states to apply
to become part of the pilot program
so that the information that is in
medicaid
and
the information from the school
will now
meet
and it will reduce significantly
the number of people that need to fill
out the free and reduced lunch form
there will still be a few people
that need to fill out the form
because they're
they
although they have health insurance
their income is
low enough that they qualify for the
free and reduced lunch program
so
that's what this non-germane amendment
is all about
is
asking doe to go forward apply
for this um
pilot program and uh
hopefully will
it will occur
and that we'll be able to
start this program
in the next year or so
and we're hoping
that it will be um
effective
so that in the 2024 budget cycle and
what the schools will be receiving in
will use this
particular program
so thank you are there
[Music]
happy to answer any questions
representative edwards for a question uh
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my questions i i'm so sorry this
first time i've looked at this bill at
all and so i'm just trying to wrap my
head around the uh construct of this
is
from a a parent's or a student's
perspective i'd like to under understand
what their benefit is
if
we do have them in a demonstration pilot
it doesn't feel to me like it gives that
school any more money it doesn't feel
like it gives that school
like a breakfast meal in addition to
what they're doing it just seems to me
from what you said that the only benefit
is reduced paperwork to the family
okay thank you for the question um
we don't know at this point what that
effect might be on the financial side of
it
because we don't know how many
people that are eligible for free and
reduced lunch have not applied
um and so
that's one of the things that we're
trying to do is to maximize
the number of people that apply for free
and reduced lunch
because it also affects our title one
programs
and how much money goes to the various
districts
based on
on title one
as far as the individual parents go
it's simply one thing
that they don't have to worry about
and it will take a lot of work off from
the um
the schools
because they're no longer going to have
to go out chasing parents to fill out
the free and reduced lunch form
follow up
okay so it sounds like the the uh two
key benefits are uh
simpler administration for the school
and anytime you have less paperwork the
better
is a rule of thumb
and then the second thing is that there
may be a monetary gain
under this theory that
some people who could be eligible for
the program just simply aren't doing the
paperwork and therefore the school's
missing out on that money
this is going to throw a wider net and
just grab
a group of people so the total number
per school might end up going up because
it's they're just being brought in by
default that's that's correct all right
thank you so much
[Music]
representative heath for a question
thank you um i just would like to add
that
in addition to those um
certain aspects that this will mean that
more children will have access to
breakfast and lunch programs
than we've seen before because often
for whatever reason a form doesn't get
filled out so we don't know that that
child may be eligible and they may end
up going a day without any kind of food
during the day so i think that's a big
plus in addition to
the increase in numbers and i think we
heard how many students
this could possibly impact was it as
high as 18 000 mark
all right yeah but it was it was
quite a number
the other thing is that in
in school funding right now
we have um
[Music]
we're using the 2019 numbers for free
and reduced lunch
at the public schools
and
that's the number we've budgeted for
22 and 23.
and so um
we need to find some way
to sort out
what we uh how many children we actually
have
in the public schools and free and
reduced lunch
because we do know
that
several students have chosen other
options
for their uh k-12 education
and how many of those are in that
category we we don't have any idea we
also know that uh overall enrollment has
gone down
so they're you know we just don't know
representative lynn for a question and
then representative petry
yes uh can you just refresh my my memory
on this i know i've heard on about this
before but if somebody
if somebody qualifies for medicaid
does that automatically mean then that
they're that they would be they would be
eligible for the free and reduced lunch
program
yes all right ask one follower follow-up
this is just on a completely different
uh
topic
relating to this is there any uh issue
any concern that by doing this
somehow the
you know privacy interests of people who
are receiving medicaid will somehow
there'll be some disclosure that
wouldn't otherwise occur that we should
be concerned about
i believe the answer to that is no
primarily because it's a pilot program
that is operating in several states at
this point
and i'm sure that all of those privacy
considerations have been
have been worked out
because that was one of the issues that
we had
in trying to do it just at the state
level
because there was concern from
dhhs i don't want to put words in your
mouth joe
i you know the concern at the at the
state level
was in
the
medicaid side
they used
names and social security numbers i
believe
and in the um
education side they only use student
numbers
you know
student identifiers so
obviously somehow or other
at the federal level it's been worked
out
represented petrie for a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question is this a precursor to uh
eliminating the forms altogether i know
we've talked about
making uh in other words funding the
entire school lunch
for everyone and then uh doing away with
the forms as part of adequacy
uh no
um
this will do away with probably 98 of
the forms
that had been filled out before
it'll just be the small minority of
people
that
qualify
but have their own
medical insurance
thank you
representative edwards for a question uh
just just curious about um
the effect on
students outside of the traditional
neighborhood schools those that have
used efas for example to go to private
schools or to home school
will will
do we think any money will follow them
or is this all meant to be
within the
four four corners of the traditional
schools
the answer is yes
the children with the efas would benefit
as well
i didn't know that thank you mark
anything further so the department of um
agriculture
is this because of food stamps is there
a connection in here with that it's
because the they're the ones that
provide the food
for the schools right and so
right now the department of agriculture
everybody gets to eat
you know they have funded 100 no matter
what
what your income level is or so on and
and so they're able to to uh access the
hhs lists
through the
okay that which we can never seem to be
able to do in the department of ed
but
through them this this will happen okay
now i understand it better
further questions
okay
thank you
representative umberger is there someone
else that would like to testify
and we'll get them to fill out a pink
card too
good evening mark manganiellos
administrator office of school finance
with the department of education
chairwoman omburger did an excellent job
describing
the what she was working on back in the
fall through the the winter as far as
the work session between
finance and education house finance and
house education
some of the key issues she she touched
on is is the fnr data has been a
long-standing
challenge for families and districts and
recently the pandemic because the usda
offered a universal waiver meaning you
do not need to fill out the application
to get the benefit of school lunch
that has significantly impacted our fnr
data so one of the main charges of that
work group was
how do we make the adequacy formula
instead of modifying the fnr data every
year how can we
uh stabilize the fnr data and this is a
solution that chairwomanberger
sort of identified as a fix to that
problem
and so if there's any i know we're good
we'll be doing some more detailed work
in division two but if there's any
questions i'm available
to answer them
any questions from the committee how do
we prevent an over count
there so
i don't think we can um
because what's talking money now
the the challenge with an over count is
essentially the way we currently operate
is we try our best to identify every
student who is experiencing poverty
inside a school we try our best and we
ask families to try their best to
identify themselves as experiencing
poverty inside of school
um
if we happen to find more students
experiencing poverty than we previously
known about i i the way this would have
to work is we have to pay
we have to count them towards adequacy
um because we are now being made aware
that there is a child experiencing
poverty in a district's responsibility
and the way the formula works and the
way kind of the constitutional construct
of the formula works is we have to fund
that
um
get a little bit into the weeds there
but that's
i would say it would be hard to to stop
an overcount
yes it would if we take away the
responsibility from the parents who
otherwise might have filled out the
paperwork and are irresponsible
then all of a sudden you're going to
have everybody qualified and
our costs for education are going to go
sky high
so these families would be these
particular families would be not filling
out the f r application but they would
be filling out a medicaid application
so
i i don't know if it correlates if
you're not filling out enough in our
application but you are filling out a
medicaid application um
it's hard to know irresponsibility
persists
they won't fill out one form they won't
fill out the other
potentially
we'll see how it all works out i guess
we're going to do this for a year and
see what happens any other questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you very much anybody
else would like to testify
please come forward identify yourself
and after you complete testifying would
you please fill out a pink card
hi introduce yourself thank you thank
you hi i'm mckenzie snow division
director of learner support at the
department of education
and i'm kelly rambo the administrator
for the office of nutrition programs and
services
thank you for coming to finance to
enlighten us you're welcome
um so i just wanted to touch upon
the application process for for this
program um it is a pilot program
um
like the two previous speakers had said
before
and we at the doe just wanted to
say that we estimate
the initial application taking
a senior individual such as myself
up to
about possibly five weeks to to complete
this depending on the the detail that is
needed for the actual application
and the application needs to be
submitted
um before september 20th of this school
of this year 2022.
um
and there could be an additional 10 to
10 to 20 hours given um
once we submit the application if
there's additional questions back from
the usda um they don't you know
maybe possibly have a question on a
procedure that we have or something
along those lines so there's the
possibility of an additional 10 to 20
hours
thus
we are requesting
that 44 000 in the cl 120 to enter into
a contract
with an entity or an individual to help
us with the application process due to
the timing
of the the process and the
the detail that is needed for that
thank you do you companion have anything
further to add
no we're happy to respond to questions
thank you
the one that occurs immediately is the
criteria for free and reduced meals and
the criteria for medicaid
how much difference is there
so this program um
uses the free and reduced it uses the
same income limits for free and reduced
as for um
that would qualify for medicaid for this
particular program so they're exactly
equal that's correct good
representative lynn for a question yes
you know what can i just ask with regard
to the quite the request for funding for
to hide you know the 44 000 that you've
asked for i guess i'm i'm i'm not it's
not clear to me if the
it sounds like from what you're saying
that this is sort of a very detailed you
said it will take five weeks to i guess
i'm
[Music]
i can you elaborate on that a little
more in other words i i thought that the
idea just from looking at this that what
you would be requesting would be access
to information
from medicaid i guess through the
department of agriculture on
the people in
a school district that
that are you know the families qualify
or are are on medicaid so i'm not
i mean
i guess i'm having trouble understanding
what's so why is that
going to take so long sure thank you for
your question um so in an ideal world
that we would just be able to request
that information from dhhs but we know
that usda requires additional
documentation that we need to be able in
order to be able to run this program
we need to submit a complete application
to them and also where this is a pilot
program for the usda
they are looking to compile all of the
the states that run this program as a
pilot to see if it's going to be an
effective program to run fully moving
forward
so just to add upon that it is an
extensive application process we have
had preliminary meetings with usda as
well as other states who have considered
and pursued this application process
and given the limited capacity of the
office of nutrition at this time we have
three staff and one administrator
historic levels of staffing have been
seven staff and an administrator so we
are concerned about the ability to
complete that application and respond to
inquiries and research a new process uh
given the capacity and thus would seek
to enter into a contract with an entity
or an individual with such expertise
thank you
representative heath for a question
thank you um
is it possible to use esser funding for
this purpose
so esther funds um at the state level
must be and in all escrow funds in fact
must be utilized to prevent prepare for
and respond to the kova 19 pandemic um
so there there is potential that there
could be a rationale there that the free
and reduced price launch applications
and paperwork
submissions have been impacted by the
pandemic but we would need to check that
would be a unique use that is not
neatly in prevent prepare for and
respond to the pandemic all right thank
you
further questions from the committee
so if someone has four children
two of them are preschool
is that reflected when they fill out the
medicaid application or is it just i
have four children
that's something that we would need to
look into based off of the data that
dhhs gives to us
i would have to look at what data is
submitted and what what grade levels are
submitted to to the doe for that i
wonder if if
medicaid asked for that detail
the ages of the children that's
something that i currently don't know
the answer to because
again we might have an over count
two or three preschool children that
somehow
are listed somewhere as free and reduced
and they're not even in school
i can find that information out for you
appreciate it thank you
okay and then i'll
just one last point if you allow me um
it might be helpful for kelly to explain
the waivers and and the factors that are
impacting the reduction in applications
very briefly
um so as mark touched upon before we are
currently in
a waiver program that expires on june
30th
and that enables all students to get
free breakfast and free lunch in school
i know that we have not received any
current information from usda that those
waivers will be extended so as it stands
right now we anticipate those waivers to
expire on june 30th and we will be going
back to
free reduced paid
processes in the schools
thank you
representative petrie for a question
have you
enumerated the cost of what it's cost
whoever for this
uh you know this waiver not not the
waiver itself but the the meals that uh
we've accumulated
no we have not projected the impact of
uh what medicaid utilizing medicaid data
instead of free and reduced price lunch
applications how that would impact
potential meals served not currently
served
right no
if i could follow up
now is that i'm i'm talking about free
and reduced in total not necessarily
just the medicaid
because that's
you know i mean how how
obviously there must be some calculation
that that we've used
as far as free release free reduced and
medicaid combined in other words whoever
got free lunch
because of the waiver
in other words is it 59 million dollars
or is it
20 million i mean what where are we at
um we don't currently have that data
information but we can get that for you
representative wallner for a question
i was wondering will this in any way
affect the child care food
program
no this is strictly for national school
lunch program thank you
seeing no other questions thank you very
much please fill out one of these for
each of you
and we will call upon director lippman
from hhs
and he's got someone else with him
oh maybe two others
yep as long as we get all the names
sometime written down
i'll do it again sorry i should know by
now right um henry lipman uh medicaid
director
don landry medicaid policy administrator
thank you for coming
medicaid's role in this is that we were
trying to be helpful to
the committee
we
are aware of this the program and i
think why
chairwoman
berger was looking at this is because i
guess in terms of your formula for
school funding you want to use data
that's you know somewhat
more
in line with the year that you're
running the formula and you know
medicaid potentially could be a support
to that
in terms of some of the questions i
heard um previously um asked by
committee members we could maybe fill in
a few blanks there
um i think you asked one um about
the do we get the age of the child on
the application we do
um
and
representative lynn asked a question
about uh you know the information that's
provided it's uh
the minimum minimum necessary in order
to to uh
to provide to the department of
education for them to be able to
administer the program
um
they're uh
you know i think from uh
you know just purely from a fiscal
standpoint in terms of your formula i
think there'd be a benefit from a
medicaid perspective um
you know we would look at the reason why
we'd want to be helpful here is that
children who
qualify for the program who also get
nutrition will probably be
healthier and consume less medical care
i don't have any data to necessarily
back that up but that's that would be
the theory behind you know medicaid
putting effort to support this with the
department of education
appreciate that
anything to add
no nothing to add thank you all right
any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you and let us know if we could be of
more help later if we have more
questions we know where you are thank
you
thank you
all right anybody else that wishes to
testify on the amendment to house bill
16 27 fna it is a non-german amendment
which is why we are holding this hearing
if i don't see any other i will call any
other questions or any other people that
wish to comment
then i will close the hearing are we
finished
hearing is closed thank you all for
coming and enlightening us
and those who haven't filled out a pink
card yet please do so
i think this is
and uh chairman umberger here she is are
we assigning this to any division
division
two is going to get it and
you're going to have a hearing on it as
well work session work session okay
all right
anybody have anything else that they'd
like to say
oh thank you i'm staying overnight
in that case
thank you all
meetings adjourned
this is so they can join some
administrative stuff
i haven't they've got enough they've got
more money than they know what to do
so they're not getting a penny i thought
there were two p's in his name i guess
you